tonight is extra special you see the
smiles on the faces of the players
but how about the fans let's make
tonight about the fans and as they came
in right around six o'clock you could
see
just how happy this group was so i'm
pretty sure that a's fans tonight
are going to have a very very good time
jose altuve digs in
crowd man i'm just going to sit and
listen to the crowd tonight it's so
great to hear them they're
letting the astros know how they feel
about them and on the first pitch of the
game el tube hits a fly ball to center
field and that is how
this 2021 season gets underway
cranky last season three and three with
a 4.03 era in 12 starts 67 innings
allowed 67 hits walk nine
and struck out 67 making his fifth
career opening day start and first in an
astros uniform
swing and a mess elevated a fastball and
olson goes down on strikes first k
for grinke to cap off a one two three in
it here's straw
mile straw he's the center fielder for
the astros
chapman's gonna have to hurry and really
run and they got a nice play by matt
chapman he knew
he had to hurry spun around and threw
out the speedy straw
i want to go after canna here runner on
third two outs grinky's going to go out
of the wind up now
curveball got him strike three is kind
of waves at it
and slams his bat down in disgust for
the third out of the innings
bregman's got a chance to knock in a
couple with a base hit now
chop towards third altuve coming home he
will score
the game's first run the play is made to
first
alex bregman an rbi ground out as altuve
crosses the plate it's one nothing
astros
good team baseball right here and a good
read by jose altuve knowing that that
was going to be a tough play
for matt chapman who makes the decision
to go across the diamond and get that
sure out at first base
tucker's the batter struck out his last
time up this one to right
pender hustling back again pinner near
the wall and he caught it
bangs up against the wall
opening night highlight real catch for
chad pinder in right field
dave the ball is carrying very well that
was kind of a half swing but tucker look
how far it goes but what a tremendous
play
by chad pindner concentration all the
way the padded wall he knows it's there
he hits it hangs on and able to come up
with a fantastic play
and now it's jose altuve standing in
with a runner at first and two out
altuve walked and scored in the fourth
right field could be trouble pinner over
pander dies and he's done it again
wow
that's a run too two terrific plays in
the game by chad pinder he saved a
couple of runs
let's take another look at chief ender
go forward stindow out there and right
to save the run
in the inning completely parallel
to mother earth chad pinder
doing work so now the astros looking for
a big two-out hit from jordan alvarez
who has popped out in flight out tonight
and alvarez
cranks this one deep to left it sends
back hannah
at the wall looking up and it's off the
wall around third scoring easily is
bregman
tucker right behind him he scores as
well a two-run double for jordan alvarez
and it's three to nothing astros
boy jordon with such good power to all
parts of the field
super loud contact on a 3-1 pitch
murphy was set up down and in that pitch
bled out over the plate
hannah stands in this is probably
grinky's last batter
and that's hit in the air to right
shallow coming in
tucker waiting for it squeezes it and
the inning is over
and grinky's probably done for the night
six strong innings doesn't allow a run
allows just three hits for the game and
that'll put runners on the corners now
on the potential tying run to the play
high in the air
tagging up as l'oreal settling
underneath it is bradley brownlee's
gonna
throw it into second base the a's are on
the board loriano scores it's three to
one so the first
run of the 2021 season four there is is
a sacrifice fly by matt
well after falling behind especially the
swing on a fast spoil inside
brings the hands in this time and able
to hit it deep enough i mean that's
power
looks like they're going to stick with
paredes for lowry opting not to turn him
around to the right side
breaking ball got him strike three gets
lowry to chase one
boy that was something that was a great
pitch out of nowhere and the catcher now
sean murphy who's over two he's at the
plate now with two outs and two men
on got him swinging strike three on the
slider
and the a strand two big pitch by
paradise he fans the last two
and will go to the eighth inning with
the astros still leading three to one
three to one astros lead it opening
night brandly has
two of the five astro hits tonight a
single and a double and he was
robbed lacing one to second his last
time up this ball hit hard again
michael brantley home run for the third
straight opening day
every year as an astro michael brantley
has hit a home run
and the astros have a three run lead
again it's four to one
here's bregman he has a double and an
rbi and a ground out
and bregman crushes one deep to left
field
and you can kiss it goodbye back to back
jacks
first brantley now bregman five to one
astro
boy he knew it right away that was a
blast to left field
upper deck for bregman and the astros
are flexing their muscles late
and the astros can put a big dent into
opening day hopes for a's bands with one
swing from kyle tucker
tucker into center field loriano is
there altuve will tag altuve heading
home
and he will score the astros sixth run
of the game it's now a six to one game
on the sac fly by kyle tucker
angered one so far he's just gotten the
one out on the sac fly
the 01 breaking ball inside and off
murphy's glove into the backstop
brantley will score without a throw
and the astros lead grows to 7-1
good ones all over the place right now
and yordon crushes
one deep to center going back lariano
makes the catch a couple of steps onto
the warning track
that'll score another run as garcia tags
and comes home
and the astros lead 8-1 runners lead off
first and second the 0-2
swing and a miss got him on the breaking
ball and
that is the ball game the houston astros
win on opening day for the ninth
consecutive year